Now we don't know who the faster or the slower person is. But we know the
slower person takes 12 hours, and the faster person takes only 6 hours. Great
algebra skills for getting that one correct. We'll start solving this equation
by multiplying through by the lowest common denominator. Which is 4x times x
minus 6, the product of these denominators. If we multiply through by the LCD,
we'll find that he x cancels in the first term, the x minus 6 cancels in the
second term. And then, on the right hand side of the equation, the 4s' simplify
to 1. This leaves us with 4 times x minus 6, here. 4x for a second term and an
x times x minus 6 on the right hand side. Next, we'll distribute this positive
4 and this x to get our next equation. We'll combine the 4x on the left and the
right, to get 8x minus 24 equals x squared minus 6x. Now we're almost to a
quadratic expression that we can factor. We just need to subtract 8x and add 24
to both sides of the equation. This gives us 0 on the left side, x squared
minus 14x, plus 24 on the right side. Now we want to find factors of positive
24 that sum to negative 14. Those factors are negative 2, and negative 12. We
set each of these factors equal to 0, and then we solve for x. So, we find the
values of x equals 2 or x equals 12. And this might be confusing. Which answer
should we take? Before we've always had at least one of the answers be
negative. So we could eliminate it since a negative time didn't make sense. The
key is that one person is 6 hours slower than the other. So if someone was 6
hours slower than someone who could work 2 hours, we'd wind up with a negative
time. So this one would be out. This means that the slower person must take 12
hours, and the faster person could do it in 6.